well what was the vision of information
networking in 1989 is actually a reality
in today's world back in 93 we wanted to
create a testbed that could be used by
our wireless researchers we also hoped
we could build a wireless network
eventually for the entire Carnegie
Mellon campus one that would provide
high-speed Internet service to users of
mobile computers one example of that is
Wireless Andrew which was the first
large-scale wireless local area network
anywhere Wireless Andrew was a
forerunner to what we now call Wi-Fi
jovovich a Morgan myself in a few others
in my reserve you who came to Carnegie
Mellon with the idea this new Sentinel
telecommunications but let's do
something which is unique Nana was
created combining computer science and
communications with relatively rare and
Academy it's much more common today what
is less common is adding the business
and policy dimension and there we still
are among a unique group of institutions
who combine those things and this
Wealth's at the same time maintaining
serious technical depth productivity has
been growing in the u.s. at twice the
rate in the last ten years as it did in
the previous ten and the research
suggests that this is largely due to the
impact of computers and networking in
allowing us to rapidly exchange
information speed up metabolism design
and process development and
and generally improve overall industrial
productivity so I and I was created by
one company to train its engineers in a
particular field and we call it
information networking the vision I've
had is to expand from that base into
broad-based information technology and
basically to focus on cybersecurity and
also to expand from there single company
single location in Pittsburgh to
multiple companies setting their
students and these students being
trained in multiple locations in the
world so the goal of the International
Programs of the information networking
Institute are to partner strategically
partner with other academic institutions
that have an area of strength that is
important to our programs we offer our
educational program or master's program
but we also opened the door to research
partnerships the ionized also become
extremely important to Carnegie Mellon
in general and during the last two years
we have made a concentrated effort to
raise endowment money for fellowships to
our students about ten to fifteen
percent of our graduates every year
start companies and many companies in
Pittsburgh and even in the US have been
created by our graduates some of our
graduates go into places like Morgan
Stanley others go into Microsoft and
there is no program either in
engineering or in computer science that
places its graduates in such a diverse
set of career paths where the students
will get from this program is number one
jobs a job which is important but more
important they will take the piece of
Carnegie Mellon which is unique in
education they were is changing all the
time and they very feel what they are
experts is going to continue changing so
they had to be able to not only to cope
with change but also to be ahead of
change